[Musik]
bild liegt ein brisantes papier aus dem
finanzministerium vor vorhin in unsere
hände gekommen war ist die rede von
neuen finanzhilfen für die messe und
veranstaltungsbranche neue finanzhilfen
im umkehrschluss brisant ist daran die
begründung daran es besteht offenbar
weiterhin ein ausfallrisiko für
veranstaltungen in diesem jahr begründet
wird das mit den hohen corona inzidenz
zahlen genau das aber sollte ja
eigentlich nicht mehr der alleinige
maßstab der korona politik seien bei uns
ist fiat auf der dieses papier bekommen
hat philipp genau ich habe das hier von
meinen kollegen aus dem politik ressort
erhalten wir haben das wirklich gelesen
und waren schockiert ich kann es hier
einmal in die kamera zeigen dass es hier
dieser brief zwei seiten und auf der
zweiten seite da steht was was uns
wirklich massiv überrascht hat ich lese
einmal vor und zwar will das
finanzministerium 150 millionen euro
locker machen und begründet das damit
dass aufgrund der aktuell wieder stark
ansteigenden inzidenz und der
stagnierenden impfbereitschaft sowie dem
beginn der kühleren jahreszeit mit
leichterer virus verbreitung jetzt wird
es wichtig weiterhin ein großes
ausfallrisiko für messen und
ausstellungen aufgrund corona bedingter
beschränkungen besteht das heißt
zusammengefasst ist droht wieder im
herbst und winter ein massiver auswahl
von großveranstaltungen und messen und
das absurde ist das wird wieder mit der
mit dem ansteigenden incidents gegründet
aber da hatte man doch jetzt wirklich
auch gesagt darauf kommt nicht mehr an
da waren sich doch im prinzip philipp
alle einig an gesagt wir müssen auch auf
die hospitalisierungen blicken die
instruments ti hat schon lange
ausgesorgt die taugt nicht mehr als
einziger wert nachdem ein maßnahmen
ausrichten kann absolut die inzidenz
fliegt ja jetzt auch aus dem
infektionsschutzgesetz es gibt kein
minister der nicht einmal hoch und
heilig versprochen hat dass die instanz
keine rolle mehr spielen soll und jetzt
sollen wegen angeblich steigender
inzidenz veranstaltung abgesagt werden
messen abgesagt werden dass es erstmal
ein riesiger schock für die ganze
branche die er seit beginn der krise
unglaublich na das ist ja mal das erste
was abgesagt wird sind messen und
großveranstaltungen jetzt ging es ja
gerade wieder los auch mit der iaa man
hat die hoffnung dass es jetzt auch
weitergehen kann denn ein großteil der
menschen ist ja geimpft die
krankenhäuser sind nicht wirklich mehr
belastet über und überhaupt nicht mehr
gefährdet also da gibt es keinen kollaps
der irgendwie bevorsteht wie kann es
sein dass das aus dem finanzministerium
kommt offenbar ohne rücksprache dann mit
den anderen beispielsweise
gesundheitsministerium das kann ich mir
ehrlich gesagt schwer vorstellen also
offenbar scheint man in der
bundesregierung heimlich der noch an der
inzidenz festzuhalten auch wenn sie
jetzt nicht mehr im
infektionsschutzgesetz steht und nicht
mehr maßgeblich sein soll für viele
bereiche des alltags aber hier wird sie
ganz klar als begründung angeführt dafür
dass es wieder einschränkungen geben
kann und dass während andere länder auch
unsere nachbarländer beispielsweise wie
dänemark in komplett lockern wir
schaffen alles ab bei denen darf wieder
alles stattfinden und wir sprechen
gerade jetzt zum zweiten corona herbst
schon wieder von einschränkungen und von
messe ausfüllen jetzt tut man es ja auch
gerade gesagt das ist ja so ein bisschen
versteckt es ist ja versteckt denn wir
brauchen zusätzliche mittel da denkt
natürlich erstmal jeder super ist erst
mal eine gute idee zusätzliche mittel
immer gut danke aber kommt der grund was
meinst du was hat das jetzt verfolgen
wer redet da dann auch mal klartext wie
dieser winter und herbst jeder spricht
von der vierten welle für uns alle jahr
vonstatten gehen soll also was bz was
passiert mit den schulen jetzt geht es
noch um veranstaltungen ich muss sagen
wir gehen alle alarmglocken schon wieder
an weil ich denke okay wir werden also
vielleicht auch noch weitere zettel
bekommen auf denen steht wir brauchen
zusätzliche mittel denn und dann kommt
eigentlich der eigentlich aber absolut
also man sagt ja immer corona krise da
verändert sich alles am laufenden band
man kann nicht wirklich langfristig
planen aber ehrlich gesagt könnte man
manche dinge einfach ausschließen gerade
das was du anspricht schulschließung man
könnte einfach sagen es ist unsere
politische entscheidung wir machen
schulen nicht mehr dicht egal ob mehr
oder weniger alle angekündigt alle haben
die machen das immer mit zu einem trick
die sagen immer schon den höchsten nicht
wieder geschlossen werden ja dann gebt
uns doch die garantie dass keine schule
mehr geschlossen wird andere länder
haben das gemacht noch bevor überhaupt
geimpft wurde in vielen anderen ländern
gab es nie schulschließungen während
deutschlands kinder zu hause sind
mussten und das gilt ehrlich gesagt für
sehr viele maßnahmen es ist dass diese
kroner maßnahmen die waren nie ein
naturgesetz und die sind auch jetzt kein
naturgesetz es ist nicht so dass nur
wenn instanzen steigen man maßnahmen
einführen muss maßnahmen verhängen muss
das öffentliche leben einschränkungen
muss um darauf zu reagieren ist auch
nicht nachgewiesen dass viele dieser
maßnahmen irgendeinen effekt hatten ganz
oft hat man im nachhinein bemerkt
hoppala die zahlen die infektionszahlen
wenn auch ohne massnahmen gesunken
einfach weil es beispielsweise wärmer
wurde kurze erinnerung
finanzministerium wird geleitet von olaf
scholz richtig ich fand es erstaunlich
dass die korona politik im wahlkampf
überhaupt gar keine überragende rolle
spielt wie man ja annehmen könnte
vielleicht weil die menschen glauben das
schlimmste ist schon hinter uns und wir
schauen nach vorne sowohl in den tri
allen oder sonstigen diskussionen
überhaupt nicht das thema nummer eins
obwohl es uns nach wie vor beschäftigt
ja das interessante beim corona
wahlkampf ist ja die bundesregierung hat
uns lange erzählt die menschen finden
die einschränkungen super je härter der
kurs desto besser und jetzt haben wir
einen wahlkampf erlebt in dem alle
versucht haben auszuschließen dass es
irgendwie wieder zu einem london kommen
wird eigentlich müsste so die logik sein
wenn die menschen einschränkungen so
toll finden dann müsste man den einloggt
ein versprechen um gewählt zu werden
jetzt versucht man corona schön
fernzuhalten und auch warum corona im
wahlkampf kaum mehr aktuell ungelöst
also und ehrlich sagt ein grund warum
corona im kanzler wahlkampf auch keine
rolle spielt ist dass sich die spd und
die union in vielem einig sind auch wenn
man in dieses papier schaut dass wir
hier aus dem finanzministerium haben das
von spd-kanzlerkandidat scholz geführt
wird der mehrbedarf also die
finanziellen mittel die 150 millionen
die wurden ja angemeldet vom
bundeswirtschaftsministerium von peter
altmaier einem cdu-minister einem ganz
engen vertrauten der bundeskanzlerin
also er sieht auch schon das messen und
veranstaltungen abgesagt wegen werden
könnten wegen corona und
meldet bei scholz an dass er 150
millionen mehr steuergeld braucht also
union und spd arbeiten beim thema corona
wirklich hand in hand da ist man sich
eigentlich in fast allem einig
[Musik]